[Musik]
wir sind ein element vom ja kommando
österreichisches bundesheer und wir
befinden uns hier der donau um mir zu
trainieren mio ist mary time interaction
operations und wir trainieren hier das
ändern und boarden von schiffen um das
schiff unter kontrolle zu bringen
[Musik]
seine trainings objekte sind zum
beispiel schiffe die sich in der dollar
befinden so wie wir das schiff jetzt im
hintergrund haben das ist 1 85 meter
große schiff und die schwierigkeit dabei
ist dieses schiff in der strömung in der
bewegung eben zu bohren und zu ändern
wir haben auch verschiedene
möglichkeiten dazu wie man 1000
verschiedene leiter systeme wir haben
strikt ändern wir haben seile dazu um
eben außerdem vorwänden boot auf dieses
schiff zu kommen und das zu ändern
[Musik]
ziel und zweck des ordens von schiffen
ist es das schiff unter kontrolle zu
bringen das kann es verschiedene gründe
haben zum beispiel weil schmuggel
tätigkeiten auf dem schiff vermutet
werden oder wenn sich verdächtige
personen auf dem schiff bestimmten bzw
wir nicht im klaren sein was befindet
sich auf dem schiff bosse transportiert
dazu bringen wir es unter kontrolle und
überprüfen das schiff bzw nehmen
verdächtige personen
vor den dienst sich grundsätzlich
zusammen aus zwei boten zwei
schnellbooten sogenannten rät auf jeden
bord befindet sich ein einsatzteam und
zusätzlich haben wir doch ein führungs
element auf einem der boote ihre sketche
steuert koordiniert und führt
es ist mir der ball im training ist
wesentlich für uns und wichtig darüber
dass in einsätzen auch durchführen und
anwenden wir haben unter anderem an der
nordküste afrikas mehrere einsätze
durchgeführt und das quasi real dann
auch durchgemacht
[Musik]